one of the latest additions to escape
from tarkov
might be one of my favorites yet scav
karma
for me scavs have always been integral
to the game both in terms of gameplay
but also the core target of experience
and
as accessibility to newer players and
now the whole element of playing as a
scavenger through the lands of tarkov is
more fun
more experiential and most importantly
more profitable
i've always considered scavens to be the
great equalizer in tarkov nothing
ventured
everything gained the start of every
underdog story that begins with a cheeky
breaky reserve run and snowballs into
piles of rubles and a stash fill to the
brim
in a game that's quickly occupied by the
juiciest of pmcs just days after the
wipe scavrons allow the more casual less
experienced or financially challenged
players a leg up against the snowballing
armored menaces now for those players
that may rely on said scaverns and have
missed the moving and shaking of tarkov
these recent weeks what is scav karma
and how does it work
you can view your karma by looking at
your fence reputation and can be earned
in a few very easy ways firstly it's all
about that sweet sweet cooperation so
using the cob extracts as either scav or
pmc
using car extracts as either of your
characters or my personal favorite way
to gain that sweet sweet karma
revenge
killing a pmc or any scav that has done
harm to your fellow scavengers will
improve how fence and in relation
how ai scavs feel about you but what
does all this wholesome bloodshed get
you
well players with a higher reputation
with fence will spawn into their
scavenge with much better gear
more valuable loot and find the ai scavs
in the game are much friendlier to you
than they are to those who commit the
cardinal sin of scav on scout violence
in addition if you reach the very peak
of scav karma then fence will sell you
leftover
uninsured pmc gear from deceased players
most importantly though i feel that scav
karma incentives cooperation
as you are directly contributing to
stopping scavs turning on each other
and actively working together or at the
very least shifting watching over your
backs as you cautiously move to extract
as a rag tag
untrusting group waiting to be picked
off by an opportune sniper
overall i feel like this has really
helped develop the overall game to game
raid to raid vibe and experience of
escape from tarkov classically it's
always been somewhat
free-for-all regardless of what faction
you're playing as but i always felt that
it's more fitting that scavs band
together and work with whatever cursed
ak they've been unfortunate to spawn
with
against the more highly geared pmcs the
common people rising up against the
rich and the well-armed that isn't to
say that tarkov still isn't the brutal
place we all know and love
regardless of how much kindness you show
your fellow scav in the time
i've been playing since the addition of
karma i felt both hope
and the sting of betrayal i've been left
cautiously waiting at co-op extracts
only for a kind pair of scavs to pick me
up
and welcome me along to the rest of
their journey constantly watching over
their shoulder to ensure that the
stranger with a rifle that follows the
back of the pack
doesn't turn on them i've also been far
too trusting as well
signaling scavs to join me waiting for
them extract seeing them do the classic
friendly wriggle
only for them to launch a supersonic
piece of metal through my cerebellum
so that it could loot my carton of uht
milk natural cooperation was always
rare in tarkov and while it can still be
hard to come by it's
way more commonplace now that players
are getting to grips with the ups and
downs of karma
for me i always felt that this
cooperation should have been encouraged
more
tarkov is a rough place to hang out and
whether teaming up was planned before
the raid or found halfway through it
it's always beneficial to be involved
well
usually but because the idea of teamwork
and tarkov
is a fairly new concept whenever it
happens it feels all that more impactful
the scav i teamed up with was nameless
i'll never know who they were
but they watched my back as i looted
held angles for me while i healed
provided me with a beam of light when it
was dark and helped me when i was
wounded
it was a fleeting bond created on a whim
in the battlefield
with a total stranger but damn it when i
saw that pmc drop him i felt
furious he was my friend my nameless
strange filthy friend the smart play
would have been to shrug it off
as doggy dog it's ruthless out there
especially when that pmc was much more
well geared than i was
but i felt i owed it to my fallen
comrade to at least
try to avenge them
it wasn't an experience i expected to
have especially as in my hundreds of
hours in tarkov it's
mostly been a solo isolated and honestly
sometimes lonely experience
but seeing scavs that are real players
team up and create these little moments
of cooperation
i think really enriches the tarkov
experience
for any kind of player for me at least
they're interesting and unique enough
that the events
are worth more to me than the loot i
leave with or any rewards i might
receive from fence
that is unless i spawn with a labs card
in that case you'll get out of my face
and you get out of my way
now not everyone is fully sold on the
new karma system and plenty of
disheveled survivors are still
as greedy and bloodthirsty as ever that
is to be expected as we are all
still human and as such fall to human
emotions
i can't say i wouldn't be tempted to
pull a trigger if i knew my scav friend
i met in reserve had a gpu in their
backpack
but that makes the whole concept all
that more deep and
interesting both in a gameplay sense
lore sense and experiential sense
i think that this in the grand scheme of
things small change to escape from
tarkov
has done a lot to help much of the game
grow i think new players will feel more
welcome
and find accomplishments within it while
veteran players are able to make new
experiences
within the game as well and hopefully it
helps all of us go home just
a few rubles richer
in the process of making expert react
this week i have been playing a bunch
more tarkov
but this was something that just stuck
in my brain and i wanted to share my
thoughts with you all
so with that said i hope you enjoyed the
video let me know your thoughts about it
all in the comment section below
subscribe for more and as always i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you